[Music]
in donation failures in donation
donation
that's pretty [ __ ] Oh Lord yeah what
the hell came up from you it's submitted
by Jill muttering demanding numbers it
make sense when it comes out anyhow yeah
don't question anything though I got it
Timonium means Jamali
uh a youtuber is being accused of faking
a hair donation I love youtubers man go
they lie about supership it's so tight
they're trying to do everything now to
like get [ __ ] views and [ __ ] dope
dude oh man I'm going to donate my whole
entire house how dare ya I [ __ ] hate
these fake-ass youtubers me too i like
after getting caught yesterday I sent
David this video there's this youtuber I
was just crying on their IG I'm not
gonna name who is and I just had to
double check my whole mouth because when
I watched it I started laughing like a
[ __ ]
so I had to send David the video horse
cage for that exactly I wanted to back
me on that because I know I'm not David
it's just as shady as I am and as much
as the scoundrel when I watch that
started laughing my crazy act as much
fun was crying
I said it to David now that yo David in
my the devil for thinking this is
hilarious and he wrote back three rolls
of ha ha caps lock and everything I was
cracking I mean I mean for me like I'm
not even looking in the context at that
point I'm just looking at the video yeah
as a comedian like you can find anything
play yeah so like I don't know what
happened in the video per se I just
thought to do cried at a baby last the
subject matter and I've never seen
anyone really be at the bottom of their
life and go where's my phone I got it
put this on Instagram
this is the thought process god it was
too crazy yeah broke it down basically
broke down the appendix that it's
understandable but if it's as
devastating as this person was saying
why we're not saying the people you're
living okay it's out of respect out of
respect of the event with that is just
like she's kind of like that's not the
first thing I would do it you know like
it's like the Britney Spears guy yeah
that's what a reminder it reminds me of
that guy a lot lady pretty alone and it
was like under discovered but the event
was sad and I do feel for the person but
it was so it was really weird yeah so
this are you to reverb have you guys
heard of flap on yes no yes oh she's a
bunny girl yeah but since baima's
doesn't evolve
yeah she she became a youtuber
technically all heiner for youtubers now
oh yeah that she was an idea I'm gonna
shower on you she also huge on it all
minors are now I Jews and youtubers now
so there's they're just public figures
ten she bought called out I like Norton
just eighteen million followers on
Monday Oh Graham was she's [ __ ] up
firstly Tyra following so she had five
million on YouTube Instagram and what
happened was she looks over syllabuses
where she looks like okay well she's a
bigger smile so 21 years old from
Venezuela oh it's been a cool and so she
uploaded this image would like to read
yes I'll really donated my hair in caps
lock exclamation mark four times first
time I ever cut my hair Abreu
what do you think yeah I know she
happenin first time I ever cut my hair
and that's not such a lot it would be
all the way down to your [ __ ] maybe
she means like outside of the trim
probably okay a woman long hair and I've
I mean I've gotten to cut but not like
style because it was just trimming the
dead end
I wouldn't call it actual cutting my
hair but you're saying she only trimmed
her hair if that's I'm assuming that
what she means by cutting my hair that
was doing me to get there I heard she
was a nice I guess it was like downriver
but but 21 years oh I know what she
means is the first time having her hair
short that's what she uh it's Girl Talk
it's girl time she helps nobody this
image and then deleted it but really
singled and so people that saved it they
cut on and so they cut on that they're
travellers hair so these are extensions
and they also come on based on the fact
that you can't donate bleach yeah hair
is weak oh he died they can't donate
booster yeah I couldn't donate mine
because I was already died say why did I
say about a bleach hair no guy taking
discrimination like natural yeah I'm not
sure it is all dead and damaged enough
maybe the way that the cause of it yeah
who knows so then uh they'd rather have
natural hair with fleas
yes then bleached hair with no fleas
they want that deliciously good Indian
dog everybody covets their voluptuous
hair Indian people yeah you know what
happens a new post photos that are too
HD people can zoom in and didn't yeah
exactly
don't do that guy his make it blurry I
know why would she do that though so she
lies and says I'm giving away my hair
that's not even my hair I'm just giving
away extensions yeah so there was a fan
that saw this screenshotted it tweeted
at her character to explain how you
chopped off your share and donated it
Lily pons
last time I checked you can't donate
extension and so this not a fan this is
a week went crazy
an ex fan maybe she felt really
disappointed true just like I can't
believe the people that I love oh my god
I got a do this picture for myself on my
Instagram I may get a whole bunch of
extensions oh donating my hair fans are
doing the same I'll be taking a punch
we're too late yeah so oh no then she
ended up responding like this is her
explanation and then Lily pons blocked
that girl that originally
engine Bing and then she ends up
responding to everything with these
tweets saying to helps clear any
assumptions I cut my hair with the
intention of donating it sadly after
trying I learned charities who donate
wigs don't accept color treated hair so
I'm finding other ways to help those
affected by hair loss because of cancer
this is still a priority for me that's
her that's her reason as to why this is
wrong so then she showed us this photo
of her real hair and so she was just
saying that the reason why she used
extensions is because at the time that
she took the photo her real hair was
being prepared being put into a ponytail
she could still she couldn't use her
hair for that photo and so she was using
the extension doesn't reference as to
how much hair shoot why did you [ __ ]
wait exactly so that's what a lot of
people are saying - it's like well you
could have just waited I wasn't like the
photo was fully produced or anything it
was like outside on the wall with
somebody else holding the area I mean I
could understand if it was like fully
produced or whatever so these are my
hands like some of the pen it were like
I was inspired by leather plans to
donate my hair yes it's mine just a
little light from the Sun though it'd be
funny if there was like monks in on this
- oh my god for the charity you know
that's like parsley it doesn't explain
me - I'm donating my hair guys for
charity no it doesn't match my hair
color that sucks what I really liked her
because on her profile she's like a
proud latina and there's not that many
strong Latino women that is of our
generation like putting themselves out
there so I always thought that she was
like a strong figurehead but now she
kind of discredited herself which kind
of sucks yeah now she's like a lying
latina there was a lot of people giving
her a lot of [ __ ] because of this and
just everyone was laughing making fun of
it like really dude like are you really
that attention hungry that you have to
post this that's what some people read
you have to do but you know that's not
what you know I'll put it like this
though like a teen I'm not I'm not
defending her in any way but you know
people knock on this girl for being
attention hungry but you're the same
exact people that are
you know what I mean because at the end
of the day let's say the girl like I'm
just getting a different perspective
that girl who who tweeted I don't like
that right your attention hungry - you
could have messaged her that it could
have been a deer exactly could have been
like yells unless unless they don't take
the f-type an amount a pian will have to
be followed by the person I'll write an
email people have their business email
intercepted yeah their personal ways to
go about anything with David saying like
he she's purposely trying to make it
public look what she did to me she
blocked me like you don't need their
kind of suit validation from exactly
something like the thing that they're
kind of dawning on her for you are the
ones that are supporting that type of
behavior and you're also just like her
so you guys should just be happy
together you know yeah in my personal
opinion anyways you know I mean there's
a reason why I don't get any views I
think it was a person that called her
although she was looking at it as like I
got it I gotta put this out there for
the public so that the fans don't get
fooled yeah it's it's a bit of that we
don't know what her two attacks are
giving a different perspective I just
think at the end of the day you gotta be
honest yeah yeah be as honest as eyes
for this [ __ ] nobody nobody likes you
know that's so true you know what sucks
is the more honest you are the more you
don't get popular yeah we don't get
brand deals from McDonald's because
we're too [ __ ] on is the more of a
liar you are the more they want to
[ __ ] sponsor you hey talk to you
McDonald's I feel so much better for
saying be that yeah but you know what
but he was crossing his toes to get a
sponsorship you know what is then you
know what's going to happen after I said
their response or everybody's it for me
so I take that back I'm on your side
McDonald Papa Papa hahaha they spotted
me McDonald kid my father's you believe
in Christian I don't know but I gotta
[ __ ] brand deal from chick-fil-a and
[ __ ] you begun when what I [ __ ] talk
about you play all the time last year
I don't wanna [ __ ] kill somebody
this [ __ ] everything a [ __ ] E what
the hell Zoey's cuz you're the baby in
her what the [ __ ]
oh my [ __ ] I guess I'm too proud you
got your polling support you [ __ ] you
too
you know what y'all love you see I don't
[ __ ] bad thank you play your you're
too were too honest you you just don't
get rewarded for honesty in this world
all just liars do you have [ __ ] lying
sack of [ __ ] all the [ __ ] craziest
liars like you know who's they get the
most views we know their [ __ ] little
schemes we could expose the [ __ ] out of
them but we ain't those channels I'm
just going to keep it to myself because
I'm a [ __ ] hate by myself come in
Morgan I'm not going to tell I'm not I'm
not going to whistle blow and go hey
this guy didn't actually do this you
ain't no rat I know [ __ ] neuron huh
and orange it's awful I got a little
dove you somebody's lap back yes yeah
hey guys would you think of that video I
know you loved it so make sure to hit
that like button to watch more videos
check it out of here
[Music]